[Music]
at the regular ECG heart rate at the
minute is 29. oh he's gonna die the NHS
is in crisis facing challenges from
every direction we can't have continued
strike after strike after strike the
pressure is Relentless 230 patients who
really don't actually need to be here
staff and patients are demanding change
we mustn't miss the opportunity that a
crisis affords to us
for our health service every winter is
hard
[Music]
staff prepare for the west and hope the
worst won't happen
with a surge in flu pieces a burnt out
Workforce and a broken social care
system it's the perfect storm
each day on the wards of University
Coventry and Warwickshire Hospital
life-saving and life welcoming care is
giveness
[Music]
hello baby Shiloh is just ourselves
her first breaths tears touches all
experienced in a service that has
already been responsible for her health
for months born three weeks prematurely
to a proud but anxious mother
given everything that's going on with
the NHS at the moment were you nervous
about coming into hospital it makes you
nervous yeah because you know you're
using that service you're gonna need
that service at one point in the
pregnancy so it makes you nervous you
know every time you go into the hospital
you're thinking oh is it gonna is it am
I gonna be the next person in that the
government needs to listen to the nurses
and the doctors and you know people in
the NHS and really really sort it out
the newborn babies on this Ward are
under the watchful eye of Midwife Chanel
Griffiths and like elsewhere in the NHS
her department is struggling with
Workforce shortages and the demand for
more complex care we need more midwives
it's very busy it seems to be getting a
lot busier
women are having babies now
um when they're a bit older which then
brings high risk more risks of them
developing complications in their
pregnancies
since its creation 75 years ago the NHS
has brought more than 52 million babies
into the world
Shiloh is one of Coventry Hospital's
newest patients and she can expect the
NHS to care for her throughout her
lifetime or can she with the NHS winter
crisis many questions are being asked
about the health services sustainability
and its future
[Music]
cracks are already showing
here on the front line every minute
masks yeah so we've got an elderly lady
who's coming through that she's having
or had a seizure some description
Dan and Danny from the West Midlands
Ambulance Service are responding to a
category one core PCGS are all over the
place to be honest with you it's
edwina's heart
it's beating so slowly it could stop
[Music]
they call ahead to Coventry Hospital
yeah five minutes to you mate you're
definitely want to release us
Edwina is taken immediately for
emergency surgery
four days later sat upright next to her
hospital bed it's hard to believe this
is the same patience what was going
through your head in the ambulance I was
gonna die now that's what I said to one
of the paramedics
I said am I going to die he said no not
on our watch you're not Edwina knows the
outcome could so easily have been
different and I've got to praise I'm
glad our lot weren't on strike I'm glad
because I don't think I'd be here to
talk to you if our lot were on strike in
a little over a week ambulance workers
and nurses around the country will stand
together on picket lines for the first
time
striking not just overpaid but the
conditions in which they are forced to
treat patients
every week this winter 1 000 people more
have died than is usually expected
the excess deaths are in part due to
delays in emergency response times and
access to care
because money fix the NHS
money in the right places fixes the NHS
short-term projects to put a holding pen
for ambulances outside a E's doesn't fix
the NHS short-term projects to buy some
Hotel Beds For Care Home patients or
patients who need to leave Hospital
doesn't fix the NHS longer term
investment in Workforce long-term
investment in right sizing the hospital
so we've got the right number of keypads
and recognizing the care sector as a
rewarding career with progression and
presumably appropriate pay
will go a long way to helping the NHS
and your message to the unions and the
government
I don't see how these issues can be
resolved without people getting around
the table and talking about it
um we we can't have continued strike
after strike after strike there has to
be some conversation that these have to
be resolved
since emerging from the pandemic the
demands here haven't dropped
the usual summer lull is now replaced by
ongoing year-long pressures especially
here the emergency department is usually
seen as the front door of the hospital
and the pressure that builds up here is
then transferred throughout the hospital
system that's usually because of a surge
in demand but it also happens because
the hospital can't discharge the
patients who are fit to go home quickly
enough
a major issue for staff trying to get
patients into the hospital is the
struggle to get enough patience out
at its peak this went to more than 14
000 people declared fit for discharge
while waiting for packages of care
staff vacancies in Social care are up
more than 50 to 165
000 and the number of people in
full-time roles has fallen for the first
time on record as it's not just about
the Health Service it's also about
social care
we have a Department of Health and
Social care but do we really truly work
together this Hospital like many across
the country will have at least 20 of his
beds where if more social care or
Nursing Care Community Care was
available we'll be able to move those
patients through so for example in this
hospital today we've got about 230
patients who really don't actually need
to be here their acute illness has been
dealt with and they can be moved on
a surge in respiratory illnesses has
made an already difficult winter even
harder
Lindsay is only 40.
she has a serious lung infection but
also suffers from multiple chronic
conditions and requires complex care
usually Lindsay is monitored remotely
but nine days ago she was rushed to
hospital as a category one emergency is
this the first time you've been in
hospital this winter
this is
policy
future
so
Lindsay's consultant Dr Assad Ali says
extra community support for patients
like Lindsay helps to ease some of the
pressure
at the demand is incessant
how do you cope with an aging population
with complex medical problems on the
resources at the NHS house
so resources are limited and nothing
denying it and with us all living longer
and living with more conditions means
yes we do need more resources to provide
care but we also need to do an appraisal
of how best we are utilizing our
resources and whether we can
get more value
across the corridor from Lindsay ishan
she has suffered eight Strokes since
2016 and suffers from a chronic lung
condition
Sean attended hospital for routine
maintenance on her ventilator
that's when Dr Ali noticed a much more
serious issue she was very unwell a very
locked in the world very high carbon
dioxide levels if she'd stayed at home
and continued being unwell without that
intervention from you what might have
happened to Sean
are you okay to talk about it John in
front of me yeah
if I don't carry on you or don't you I'm
going to be dead
but she would have deteriorated and and
part of the process of deterioration is
to get drowsy and then comatose and then
intervention is required because one can
go into a deep sleep since the pandemic
respiratory Wards have been flat out
there is no end in size
and all this the industrial action the
flu the precious felt in the emergency
department will have long-term impacts
more than seven million people are
waiting for elective care
a list that was too long before the
pandemic has only become longer
Professor Kieran Patel is performing
surgery on an 88 year old patient
she's having a pacemaker fitted it's
routine but life-changing operations
like these that are delayed when
hospitals come under severe pressure
we mustn't miss the opportunity that a
crisis affords to us and one of the
benefits is that it will force us to
transform the way in which we deliver
Health Care we'll need to get better at
knowing where our demand comes from what
it looks like so we need to move from
being a reactive Health Service to being
a responsive Health Service and
ultimately being a predictive Health
Service on the ground floor of the
hospital cocooned from the tears and the
trauma is an oasis of calm
this space provides respite from the
intensity
for both patients and staff
multi-faith leaders here provide
material
and spiritual support
staff are very tired
but at the heart of that people are
vocational about these jobs you know you
come to work because you're a caring
person who wants to care and wants to be
able to be in a caring space in these
times of pressure and you know scarcity
that makes that difficult sometimes and
um and we have to be kind to ourselves
and each other in that you know we can't
sort of be superhuman
baby Shiloh should grow up expecting the
NHS to be there for her
as it is for Lindsay every time she
needs Urgent Care
and for Edwina
when it saved her life
but its future is anything but says it
Ashish Josh is Sky News in Coventry
Hospital